so the interesting thing is that the eye
bows are you know robots that allow you
to do perception cognition and action so
they can sense the world make decisions
and actually move in addition they can
talk with each other and therefore we
can create systems of multiple robots
that create teamwork in very complex
situations so if you look at this there
is one attacker that goes to the ball
and he's going to kick the ball towards
the goal down the field but the
interesting robot to look at is its
teammate who is active as an offensive
supporter moves down the field always
seeing the ball but not going to the
ball because its role is just to support
the attack until the moment that after
the attacker kicks into the goal the
ball rolls into a position where it was
ready to receive it and scores as a
beautiful offensive supporter so this is
the model that we have been using more
recently but we have experienced all the
sequence of the models and making use of
the villians features throughout the
years
you